[Música]
un nuevo intento por parte de la reserva
federal para frenar la inflación en eeuu
es tal vez la noticia más destacada de
la jornada en términos económicos y está
con nosotros jorge hurtado para darnos
más detalles buenas noches jorge qué más
dicen allí en eeuu porque suben más las
tasas bueno la fed no descarta nuevas
subidas del próximo mes precisamente
porque algunos indicadores económicos
muestran que la economía de eeuu sigue
bastante activa el banco central subió
las tasas de interés es 75 puntos
básicos si se suma este aumento y el de
junio se acumuló un incremento de 150
puntos básicos es el más grande desde
1980 la idea de santiago al subir los
tipos de interés es desacelerar la
economía pero no existe un vigoroso
mercado de trabajo y las tensiones por
la guerra en ucrania que ponen más
presión a la inflación que se situó en
9,1 por ciento anual en junio la
decisión de la fed hizo repuntar el euro
que cotizó cerca de 102 dólares con el
dólar también perdiendo casi
0,75 por ciento y asimismo los mercados
cerraron en positivo tras esta noticia
porque toman decisiones pero que hay de
los temores de una posible
aunque dicen las autoridades allí bueno
precisamente el trabajo de la reserva
federal de eeuu es desacelerar la
economía pero no tanto como para causar
una recesión económica yo rompo way
quien es presidente de la fed dijo que
no ve en la economía cayendo en recesión
esto mientras varios sectores de la
economía muestran un buen desempeño
jared bernstein quien es uno de los
asesores económicos del presidente de
joe biden secundo esta idea la casa
blanca no cree que la economía vaya a
recesión pero dijeron que seguirán de
cerca el informe de este jueves sobre
los datos del producto interno bruto
tradicionalmente una economía entra en
recesión cuando encadena dos trimestres
seguidos de caída del producto interno
bruto pero el funcionario argumentó que
hay otros factores como la fortaleza del
mercado del trabajo o el gasto de los
consumidores ambos en buen estado que
deberían tenerse en cuenta antes de
declarar una recesión económica
escuchamos y que dijo powell cuando le
preguntaron precisamente sobre este tema
habrá recesión en eeuu 1
no creo que eeuu esté actualmente en
recesión y las razones que hay
demasiadas áreas de la economía que
están funcionando muy bien y por
supuesto yo señalaría el mercado laboral
en particular
y seguimos dando seguimiento a los
resultados de las grandes empresas en
eeuu hoy hablamos de meta que es la
matriz de facebook e instagram y
whatsapp también bueno la empresa
informó de la primera caída de sus
ventas trimestrales y precisamente culpó
a la reducción de los presupuestos de
los anunciantes los ingresos de meta
cayeron a 28 mil 800 millones de dólares
en el segundo trimestre por debajo de la
estimación media de los analistas
mientras que la previsión de la empresa
para el trimestre actual también se
quedó corta las ventas de publicidad de
la empresa se están topando con varios
problemas uno de ellos santiago es que
los vendedores están gastando menos
debido a diversas presiones económicas
que ya mencionamos como la inflación
también las normas de privacidad de
apolo hicieron que los anuncios en
facebook e instagram sean menos eficaces
otro factor es que en un esfuerzo por
competir con otra red social famosa como
stick tok
y sociales están mostrando a los
usuarios más vídeos de formato corto y
esto hace que no gasten tanto dinero en
publicidad con este tipo de alcance
orgánico que están logrando otra empresa
que presentó sus números y que tal vez
no le fue muy bien fue best buy si la
empresa prevé una mayor caída de sus
ventas anuales esto se interpreta como
otra señal de que los consumidores están
sintiendo la presión del aumento de los
precios y frenando el gasto en artículos
no esenciales como computadoras y
televisores los a las acciones del
minorista cayeron un 3% en la bolsa
después de que best buy también
pronosticar a una caída del 13 por
ciento de las ventas del trimestre
actual y pusieron pausa sus programas de
recompra de acciones precisamente ayer
comentábamos una situación similar para
walmart que el lunes recortó su
previsión de beneficio la gran cadena
minorista considerada un termómetro de
la economía de eeuu asegura que el
aumento de los precios de la gasolina y
los alimentos hace pensar dos veces a
los consumidores sobre cómo gastar su
dinero y para el cierre de esta sección
hablamos de el senado de eeuu que aprobó
un proyecto de ley que busca fortalecer
la de suministros en ese país cómo
funcionará bueno se trata de un subsidio
que ronda los 52 mil millones de dólares
para la fabricación de microchips la
idea de washington es mejorar la
posición de eeuu en su competencia con
china en este sector la normativa
contempla en total una inversión de 280
mil millones de dólares de los que 52
mil millones están pensados para
fomentar la instalación de fábricas
nacionales de semiconductores antes el
proyecto debe pasar todavía por la
cámara de representantes aunque los
demócratas ahí tienen mayoría la
economía global se ha visto afectada
desde la pandemia por la escasez de
estos microchips que son necesarios para
la fabricación de vehículos y
electrodomésticos muchas gracias jorge
por esta actualización de las noticias
del mundo de la economía es todo por el
momento en directo américa ya viene el
debate
[Música]